Nous on est un petit peu un comptoir de vente.
Mais c'est alimentaire hein.
Parce qu'à la moindre opportunité, on s'empare du trône, hein.
Et quand je dis "opportunité", je veux plus dire "complot".
Et quand je dis "on", c'est plus "moi".
Et quand je dis "trône", bah c'est...
Ah bah non... C'est "trône".
C'est ça.
Alors, pourquoi les potions ?
Bah alors en fait, moi, un matin, y a un ami qui vient me voir...
Il me dit "ouais je crois que j'ai le tétanos et tout, machin".
Donc il part chercher une potion.
Puis, alors, en fait, plus de potion.
Donc mon pote est mort.
Et je me suis dis, les potions on va les faire sur place.
Parce que si nous on veut acheter des épées et des arbalètes, y en a partout.
Alors que les potions, y en a pas !
On les fabrique ici !
Du baume du tigre, vous en avez ?
Et bah nous on en fabrique ici.
Et ça, sur le Royaume, personne en fait.
C'est notre truc à nous, ça.
C'est la guerre, les gens sont souvent mal.
Du coup, on est un petit peu en rupture de stock.
Aujourd'hui, on reçoit un envoyé de la maison des loups du Nord.
Je les trouve sympa, hein, mais...
Ils ont les cheveux gras.
Et moi, ça me gêne quand ils disent des trucs sérieux.
Vous présenterez nos excuses à votre seigneur.
Les plantes n'ont pas donné ce qu'on espérait.
Cela est fâcheux, Frogz.
Le chef des loups est mort.
La période est trouble, il faut le ***, le temps presse.
Oui... j'ai pas... y a un mot que...
Un nouveau roi du Nord se dresse.
La main du roi c'est un ***, le lion et le cerf le guellour.
Le gellour ?
Guellour, pour moi, c'était comme des toutes petites chaussures.
En peau.
Fourrées.
Donc lui, guellour, et moi j'ai...
L'hiver arrive.
Je sais. Parce que vous répétez ça depuis le début.
Mais, déjà, est-ce qu'on est sûr de ça ?
Parce que moi je me demandais, est-ce qu'on pourrait pas décaler l'hiver ?
Parce que vous là, en terme de mois, vous en êtes où ?
Mi-octobre ?
Novembre ?
Je cherche hein...
Vous avez passé Halloween ?
Quoi ?
Quand un client a un truc en tête...
Aelys a réussi à faire venir un guerrier...
De la région la plus mystérieuse du Royaume.
S'il accepte de nous aider, on est sauvé.
Je les trouve fascinants moi, ces gars-là.
Ils sont à moitié sorcier, à moitié guerrier.
J'adore.
Et parle un peu comme des demeurés aussi, c'est marrant.
L'homme doit tuer.
L'homme a besoin du poison qui tue l'homme.
Fort bien, noble guerrier.
Et justement, j'ai plusieurs poisons à vous proposer.
Et notamment une petite plante verte.
Si on l'utilise bien, peut... Oh !
L'homme a changé de visage ?
Ouais.
L'homme a changé de visage.
L'homme a pas prévenu.
Du coup, l'homme a flippé.
C'est pas grave.
Si vous avez besoin d'autre chose...
J'ai aussi un poison extrêmement mortel.
Qui peut... Oh !
Pardon.
L'homme est en detox.
L'homme est cool.
L'homme a besoin de 30 secondes.
L'homme a chaud, il fait chaud ?
On est sauvé.
Le guerrier a accepté de nous fournir du lait de pavot en échange de poison ?
L'homme est super.
On est de retour dans la course au trône.
Et ça, c'est la bonne nouvelle du jour.
Avec la baisse du prix du foin !